>> HARRY, THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> LET'S GO TO ALISYN CAMEROTA.
YOU JUST HEARD HARRY, EVERYBODY
SETTLE IN, GET COMFORTABLE.
I DO THINK WE NEED TO ALWAYS
REMIND ME THAT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY ELECTION DAY, IT'S
ELECTION WEEK OR IT'S EVEN
ELECTION MONTH.
HOWEVER, THAT'S NOT WHAT SOME
RIGHT WING FRANKLY TRUMP ALLIES
ARE ALREADY DOING.
CHRISTINA BOB ONE OF HIS FORMER
LAWYERS YESTERDAY SAID ON A
RIGHT WING NETWORK THERE SHOULD
BE ABSOLUTELY A RESULT NO LATER
THAN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT,
MEANING TONIGHT, OR EARLY
WEDNESDAY MORNING.
I THINK THOSE AREAS THAT DON'T
HAVE A RESULT IT'S GOING TO LOOK
VERY SUSPICIOUS.
IN OTHER WORDS, ALREADY PLANTING
THE SEED OF DOUBT.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I'M FROM MICHIGAN AND WE KNOW
THAT IN DETROIT THEY COUNT VOTES
A LITTLE LATER, YOU HAVE A
HIGHER DENSITY OF PEOPLE.
SO FEWER ELECTION OFFICIALS
COUNTING MORE VOTES WILL TAKE
MORE TIME.
THIS IS A WAY OF TRYING TO SET
THE TABLE AROUND THE FACT THAT
REALLY ONLY THE RURAL VOTERS OR
THE SUBURBAN VOTERS ARE THE ONES
THAT YOU SHOULD BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO.
SO IT REALLY IS WORRYING BECAUSE
THIS IS A STRUCTURAL REALITY OF
WHAT IT TAKES TO COUNT VOTES.
>> THIS IS WHY -- I MEAN, ALL
THE RACES ARE IMPORTANT AND I
KNOW WE'RE ALL WATCHING, YOU
KNOW, SENATE, PENNSYLVANIA,
SENATE GEORGIA, BUT THE THREE
RACES THAT I THINK ARE MOST
IMPORTANT ARE KRISTINA KARAMO IN
MICHIGAN, MARK FINCHEM IN
ARIZONA AND JIM MARR SHAND IN
ARIZONA.
THEY ARE ALL ELECTION DENIERS.
THEY HAVE ALL SUGGESTED IN SOME
WAY THAT THEY MIGHT NOT CERTIFY
ELECTIONS, THAT THEY MIGHT
REFUSE.
>> UNLESS THEY WIN.
>> UNLESS THEY LIKE THE RESULTS.
AND THEY'VE TRIED -- THEY'VE
TRIED IN THE PAST, THEY WANT TO
TRY AGAIN.
I THINK THOSE MIGHT BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELECTIONS.
YOU MIGHT NOT FEEL THEM, I
UNDERSTAND POCKETBOOK ISSUES AND
CRIME, I GET THAT, BUT THAT'S
THE FUTURE OF FUTURE ELECTIONS
AND DEMOCRACY.
>> BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY S
REMEMBER, WE'VE SEEN THIS MOVIE
BEFORE.
THIS IS VERY TRUMPIAN AND
ACTUALLY LET'S REMEMBER THAT
SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGAL
TEAM THAT WERE BEHIND TRUMP'S
LEGAL STRATEGY IN 2020 ARE
WORKING IN THESE VERY STATES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SET UP A
NARRATIVE THAT SAYS IF IT'S NOT
A RED WAVE, SOMETHING WENT
WRONG.
>> YEAH.
>> AND SO THAT'S PART OF WHY
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS SO IMPORTANT
TO REMIND PEOPLE IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TIME.
WE'VE GOT TO BE PATIENT.
AND THE THING ABOUT THAT IS THAT
MEANS THE SYSTEM IS WORKING.
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT MEANS VOTES ARE GETTING
COUNTED, THAT MEANS WE'RE
WORKING OUT WHATEVER QUESTIONS
THERE MIGHT BE ABOUT PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS OR WHAT HAVE YOU.
THAT'S HOW IT SHOULD BE TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVAN AUTO THE VOTES
THAT ARE CAST LATER TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA GET COUNTED WITH THE
SAME VERACITY AS THOSE THAT GET
COUNTED EARLIER TONIGHT.
>> EXCEPT I WORRY THAT THE
PEOPLE MOST SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE
SUSPICION ARE NOT WATCHING RIGHT
NOW AND SO ALL OF THESE SEEDS
THAT ARE BEING PLANTED THEN
WHAT, CHARLIE?
>> LOOK, IN PENNSYLVANIA THERE
ARE 1.1 MILLION ABSENTEE
BALLOTS.
NONE OF THEM COULD BE PROCESSED
UNTIL THIS MORNING.
>> YEAH, BY LAW, RIGHT?
>> BY LAW.
NOW.
THE LEGISLATURE THEY COULD HAVE
CHANGED THIS AND ALLOWED THE
PROCESSING OF THESE THINGS MAYBE
A WEEK IN ADVANCE BUT THEY CHOSE
NOT TO DO IT SO WE WILL PROBABLY
NOT HAVE AN OUTCOME TONIGHT.
IT TOOK US TO SATURDAY TO DO 3.5
MILLION IN 2020 SO MAYBE IT WILL
TAKE A COUPLE DAYS TO GET THERE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE ON PEOPLE'S
MINDS AS THEY TELL US WHEN THEY
COME OUT OF THESE VOTING BOOTHS.
THESE ARE A COUPLE OF VOTERS IN
WISCONSIN WHO ARE JUST SHARING
THEIR DIFFERING PHILOSOPHIES
BASICALLY.
>> I THINK IT'S REALLY ABOUT
SAVING OUR DEMOCRACY AND MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE.
KIND OF FIGHTING THE POLITICAL
DIVISIONS.
SO, YEAH, IT'S ABOUT MAYBE WE
CAN CONTINUE WHAT WE'VE
CONTINUED TO DO.
>> THE ECONOMY IS DEFINITELY A
BIG ONE AND TO BE FRANK WITH
YOU, IT'S JUST -- LIKE THERE
SEEMS TO BE MUCH MORE CARE ABOUT
THE SEXUALITY OF PEOPLE AND NOT
PEOPLE STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
RENT OR PAYING THEIR MORTGAGE.
>> AND THERE IT IS, ABDUL, THEY
CAPTURE IT PERFECTLY.
>> YEAH.
ONE OF THE REALLY INTERESTING
OUTCOMES OF A POLL THAT CAME OUT
JUST ABOUT A WEEK BEFORE THE
ELECTION WAS THAT 70% OF
AMERICANS AGREED THAT DEMOCRACY
WAS IN CRISIS BUT ONLY 17% OF
THEM ATTRIBUTED THAT TO
AUTHORITARIANISM, THE REST
TALKED ABOUT CORRUPTION AND THE
WAYS IN WHICH A LOT OF DEMOCRACY
FEELS LIKE IT IS -- IT'S HAD THE
TALONS OF BIG CORPORATIONS PUT
INTO IT.
AND I THINK THAT AS WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT COMES OUT OF THIS
ELECTION, IT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY CRITICAL FOR US TO BE
ASKING HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
BEYOND SAVING THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY VOTE FOR YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES WE'RE ALSO
ASKING HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE
REMOVE THE OBSTACLES THAT A LOT
OF FOLKS FEEL LIKE ARE GETTING
IN THE WAY BETWEEN THEIR
POLITICAL WILL AND THE OUTCOMES
OF OUR ACTUAL PUBLIC POLICY.
>> I MEAN, I'VE BEEN COVERING
LOTS OF RACES OVER -- WE ALL
HAVE AND TO ME IT FEELS LIKE
REPUBLICANS TALK A LOT MORE
ABOUT GENDER AND PRONOUNS AND,
QUOTE, UNQUOTE, GROOMERS THAN
DEMOCRATS HAVE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, BUT REPUBLICANS ARE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT CRIME AND
INFLATION IN WHICH IS THAT I
THINK JUST GET RIGHT TO VOTER
FEARS.
FEARS THAT ARE REAL IN MANY
CASES.
I DON'T THINK DEMOCRATS WERE
WRONG TO TALK ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
BUT YOU CAN'T GO OUT THERE AND
SAY THE ECONOMY IS GREAT.
YOU CAN'T BE JOE BIDEN AND SAY
THE ECONOMY IS STRONG AS HELL.
YOU CAN'T BE RON KLAIN AND SAY
EVERYTHING IS FINE WE'RE NOT
PLANNING FOR A RECESSION.
YOU JUST CAN'T TELL VOTERS
THEY'RE WRONG TO HAVE FEARS
ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND CRIME.
I THINK THEY COULD HAVE DONE IT
ALL, THEY REALLY CHOSE TO SORT
OF MARGINALIZE THOSE ISSUES.
>> FIRST OF ALL, WITH HE NEVER
WANT TO TELL VOTERS THEY'RE
WRONG BECAUSE THEY SURELY DO NOT
LIKE TO HEAR THAT, LET ME TELL
YOU.
LOOK, I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
WITH CANDIDATES, THERES NOT A
SINGLE CANDIDATE ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE THAT HAS ONLY
RUN ON A SINGLE ISSUE BECAUSE I
THINK AS WE SAW IN THAT TAPE
VOTERS ARE CARRYING A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> THE ECONOMY IS IMPORTANT.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT CRIME.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
SO MOST OF THE ADS I'VE SEEN --
AND, REMEMBER, THERE'S A LOT
THAT'S GOING ON UNDER THE
SURFACE, GRASSROOTS ORGANIZING,
CANVASSING THAT ISN'T AS MUCH
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ON
TELEVISION BUT THAT IS GOING
DIRECTLY TO SOME OF THOSE DEEP
CONCERNS.
>> REPUBLICANS OVERSTATE VOTER
FRAUD, DEMOCRATS OVERSTATE VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
IT